and for the raise taking the mound this
afternoon right-hander charlie morton
and he has
slowly but surely been rounding into
form he has thrown the ball better and
better
each of his first three starts including
his last one where he picked up a win
went five and two thirds innings against
the red sox giving up just
one earned run now aaron judge thompson
home runs in the big leagues with
eight and he shoots a fly ball
into right throw is there to make
the catch and back into first goes lemay
here
hicks is seven for 34 a homer and
three rbs pitch a breaking ball
swung on and lying down the right field
line and it's one hop
off the right field wall renfro fires in
gj holds it third on the double by hicks
so the yankees a couple of solid hits
and
they have second and third and one man
out
and that's going to bring up mike ford
faces loaded two men out
the 2-2 inside and it hit him and the
yankee score run the tough way
the ball sailed inside and hit ford i
think
in the arm so ford gets an rbi lemay who
scores and the yankees take a
one-nothing lead
and the big maple on the hill down in
tampa for the yankees today and you see
only four innings pitched in his first
two starts
one nothing yanks bottom the first one
on one out
and here's the right hand hitter jose
martinez big tall right hand hit it with
power hits the ground ball at the third
a shell at the second one and on to
first
it is a double play lemay who
had tough time digging the ball out of
his glove but he still made the play
so that is a five four three gp no runs
one hit
so the count full three and two so now
le mayhew
will be off and running from first on
the 3-2 to judge
swung on and hit high in the air to
shallow right center
margot comes on and renfro comes in
front to make the catch
and in the inning no runs one hit one
left
the end of an ending and a half the 3-1
and a walk to hicks
this uh this is never good when you have
your manager and the trainer
headed to the mound to talk with your
starting pitcher a walk here to hicks
doesn't look
good and that's going to be it for
charlie morton he was removed from the
game
with right shoulder inflammation he will
continue to be evaluated and monitored
so richards will get the call
that is strike three call on the outside
corner
boyd caught looking well all that
warm-up watching apparently didn't help
him
it did not help him and guess what and
richards gets a call here
on the fringe two down for the number
nine hitter brad gardner here's the o2
it's hit hard base it over third toward
the left field line
fielding in his meadows gardner hustles
towards second and he is there with a
double
you knew gardner would try for it and
the throw was offline
you know not every throw is going to be
right on the bag rosso
had a fly ball of center that was in the
second two away
fastball street right three he struck
out the side paxton
has eight strikeouts in four innings
only one out
still got another opportunity to just
get a couple more on the board
gio rochelle at the plate and richards
deals swung on and hit high in the ear
to center field
back goes margot on the track near the
wall drops it
he dropped the ball and two runs will
easily score the yankees get
a big fat break doesn't matter how they
score it it's two runs
and the yankees lead three nothing that
ball should have been caught it would
not have been an easy play but it should
have been caught
nonetheless the yankees get two runs
paxton does not want to get off the
rubber he's just waiting
waiting for the guy to get in the box
love it if you're a young pitcher
emulate this swinging and a miss
strikeout number nine
for paxton paxton has allowed one measly
hit a ground ball hit he's walked one
hit of batter
and has struck out 10. the 2-2 struck
him out swinging great slider down and
away
strikeout number 11 for paxton he can't
pitch
one thing he can't pitch better than
this he really can
also for the fly ball to center and a
strikeout he was caught looking in the
fourth
rays have placed a man in scoring
position for the first time
there's a drive high and deep to left
and brusso has hit it out
on the board and just like that it's a
one-run ball game
now a strike to count on brandon lau
and now lau connects this one deep to
right and that baby
is gone back to back from rosso and lao
and this game is tied at three
they got greedy they got way too greedy
with paxton he was throwing the ball
well
but all of the ups and downs and it has
come back to bite the yankees here and
now the ray's got to finish the job
and obviously he's very frustrated
because he fits so beautifully but
the home run de brusso and then the home
run to lao two and two
let's see it again pace is loaded one
out bottom of the eighth
high game ground ball third
down to second one first he's safe there
and the rays will take the lead and you
know the yankees are going to take a
peek at this because it was that
close now they are going to challenge
decision is he's out
they have overturned it perez has wanted
that old for one against britain
a chance to be a hero and a
base head under right field razor going
to win it
wow scores on the single on the right
by michael perez it's a 4-3
raise victory and they take three of
four from new york